[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome to this
week's thoughtful Thursday I brought my
man Dave Mason on to the show to talk
about the lease option agreement that he
recently recently did I promised to
bring him on to answer all the questions
that you guys had so Dave welcome to the
thoughtful Thursday oh I'm good so how's
your lease option going it's amazing
I've got a whole bunch of questions
right here okay because people have been
literally hundreds of people have been
reaching out on YouTube about this crazy
deal yeah it wasn't even a particularly
amazing deal like people get deals all
the time on a no-money-down basis yeah
these options buy now pay later
but for some reason yours caught so much
attention because of how well-documented
it was so if you guys haven't seen the
video check it out so first one did you
really secure that house with no money
absolutely yeah none of my money went
into that house I've secured the house
in nómine and people go oh man that's
impossible you can never do it what
about a penny or a pound or doesn't they
understand that that house is now my
house and I'm not giving any money
towards it the the house is mine yeah I
mean I mean yeah I mean the title deeds
aren't yours yet yeah the title deeds
but you have the option to buy the title
deeds in five years yeah for how much
sixty seven and a half thousand pounds I
see seven a half thousand pounds but
right now you're you're benefiting from
the house it's been given to you so
you're getting all the rental income you
get in all the capital appreciation so
it's as if you own it but but
technically you don't yeah I don't get
why people are so negative about it
they're like well what happens if this
what about the void the first question
that came up quite a lot is people said
great the rent have you got a tent now
yeah working tenant no I had a refurb
yeah there's a working tenant in there
all the sort of saying is you've got a
tenant lien there's paint how much four
hundred and fifty pounds fifty pounds
you've got to pay the mortgage payment
to the landlord
yep which is 200 pound doing the bone
and then you've got the management fees
yeah ten percent ten percent of 450
about fifty queers yeah so you're only
actually going to be making 150 gross so
you might having you
pakhi hundred fifty quid or whatever it
is but people are saying but the thing
is is that right no 220 pounds 200 pound
in your back pocket what people are
saying is but you did a little refurb
you spent how much 1,700 quid so people
are saying is what your first year is
written off then isn't it and then a net
and that that's their big gripe what
would you say to them I would say to
them yeah it probably is and I've got no
issues with that whatsoever I know the
first year was going to be something
like that but they're not thinking of
the second year the third year the 40
the fifth year and they're certainly not
thinking about the cups of appreciation
I don't get it if I said to you right
there's 200 smackers that's 200 quid
Samuel you've got it for the next five
years and then in five years you can
have some capital appreciation on the
house you're going to benefit from the
five years and the capital appreciation
and there's 200 pound there but you're
gonna have to put a little bit of
refurbishment in you know it's a
no-brainer an absolute no-brainer yeah
it's a win for them it's a win for me
and if I've done it once I can do it
again and if I do it again then that
kind of eradicate their whole issue with
all the first years are right off you've
got to take a risk anything terrific
though the first chair being a write-off
is let's say this let's say the first
year is a complete write-off well what
that actually means is another way of
saying that is yeah the first chair is
going to give you a 100% return on your
money exactly so so what it's a no
brainer I'm gonna get a deal that gives
you a 100 percent return on investment
oh but what about the first year yeah
what about the first year so you think
it's a ridiculous question yeah I think
it's ridiculous question because it's an
investment and the the whole idea of an
investment is I'm investing my time my
energy and my effort sealing the deal
capturing the deal not for literally a
return on investment right now yeah for
a return on investment and can I say
that playing out yeah and interesting as
well that 1750 that you put down didn't
you do that on a credit card anyway yeah
so you didn't actually yeah I'm not
taking out our savings
I'm not taking out of anything I've got
a perfectly I could of yeah but I've
chosen to go down the credit card
because guess what I know that's not
tangibly my working capital yet the
money that I have to think all what
about this what about that so it's come
from a credit card it will pay itself
back off anyway and guess what this time
next year
a year from now from this update of this
video I'll be zinnia and guess what my
crazy year is gone and I'm already into
profit from my second year third year 40
or 50 year and I know that I can use
those skills for life yeah I can get I
can get another lease option agreement
I'm working on many different projects
now yeah and when they come to fruition
and they're they're there and they're
active and they're live this time next
year I'm not gonna worry about all about
the virtual investment I think it's a
mindset you have to change your mindset
breach it day next question where did
you find the tired landlords from ah do
you know what the I know this is crazy
answer with the honest answer is
everywhere
the tied landlords everywhere if you
don't go looking for them they're
everywhere
sometimes you find them through gum
trees sometimes you find properties on
Rightmove
I've been there for years and years and
years you have to get out there the best
due diligence is these you've got to get
out there you've got to know I know on
this occasion I know it was someone that
was referral from someone in the office
but the bottom line is do you know when
you get you get a new a new car or
something it's suddenly you see them
everywhere on the road yeah it's like
wow I didn't really talk on with this
car was yeah well I bought it it was the
first time I'd seen that no.19
everywhere in the same way when you know
how to find a tired landlord summer
everywhere yeah they are yeah absolutely
I couldn't have put that any better and
a lot of people ago is referred to me
had it handed on a play he were actually
some your leaves and the office know if
I hadn't put myself out there if I
hadn't have had that meeting if I hadn't
have phoned these people if I hadn't
have actually said look I want to be a
property investor look I want a deal
look I'm ready to go look I've got a
limited company or by the way look I've
actually set up a limited company which
cost ammo is hardly anything like 17
quid on - Marcy I got a four set up a
company that gosh ago and everyone said
you know it's easy they can't afford to
set up a company but then they can
afford to go to Nando's yeah when they
cost the same yeah you know anyway how
many houses did you visit before
securing this no money down a lease
option agreement a oh okay none
Wow that was your first one yeah let's
say it like it is it that's the truth
Norden below i looked at a hundred
houses before that was your first one
yeah there's my first one I knew I was
doing I knew the questions to ask you a
crash course and the knowledge from that
has set me up perfectly that was the
next question actually someone said
was it just from the crash course alone
that you've got the knowledge to secure
the deal do you know what yeah I'm gonna
be totally transparent about it I'm not
reading some golden manual this is your
crash course great it's called the
knowledge from that the education from
that game in the knowledge and then I've
basically gone right okay I can oh if I
have the knowledge and not use it or I
can try and apply that knowledge and
actually do something with it yeah and
do you know honestly I never Anton I do
apologize but it just gets on my nerves
that people are like oh you know it's
only 200 quid it's only 200 quid and
that's why they'll probably ever get one
yeah it's that negativity it's that oh
you bought about this what about that
well if you never try it and you never
know then you're never gonna be in a
situation where you can go actually you
have tuned to found at school man I'm
happy that do another 40 grand yeah and
what about the contacts from it as well
they don't see that side they don't see
the phone calls that come in afterwards
the joint ventures I would like to do a
lease option email but don't know how to
do one so Dave can you help me yeah
actually yeah let's work together and so
what you could say is this is a
springboard for my property portfolio so
you know that's why I get so passionate
about you know someone set here said low
you say you've just bought a house for
free and you're now a property investor
but your car was terrible it looks like
it was worth about five hundred pounds
my car they see your cars worth five
hundred pounds yeah yeah I say by that
is they're right there correct my car
was you know what actually I think it
was less is worth less than five hundred
quid
you've got a new one sits in there I'm
actually yeah you got that lease option
agreement about three weeks ago you put
the video out just right afterwards in
your banger yeah but since that and now
you mean you're doing well in life on
yeah yeah yeah another car I'm actually
gone and bought a supercharged Toyota
gt86 limited edition I don't know what
that it's silver pearlescent paint it's
great I don't know what car that is
because I'm not great with cos me it
sounds like a sports car
good job good job
alright so you were driving a banger now
you know you know what that's completely
irrelevant anyway and I was there's no
people
a car is a liability yeah I choose to
put more money into assets rather than
liabilities I don't particularly live a
luxurious lifestyle I mean I do drive a
decent karma stuff like that but you
know what I've been in the game 11 years
now but for the first five years of my
property career yeah even when I was a
property millionaire I was driving like
a ten-year-old car and I was living in a
3-bedroom semi-detached town people
judge that but the people that judge
that are absolute broke themselves so
trying to impress losers and spending
money on liabilities to impress people
who are broke themselves yeah is a
ridiculous thing to do I'd rather live
humbly invest Wow totally grow and live
for a pedigree couldn't agree more
says the man in the sports car yeah but
I mean I love my cars and anyway so I've
always wanted one so why not I'm doing
well for myself property portfolios are
gaining traction as we speak I'm living
my job and my outlook yeah so it doesn't
make you think you know I do think that
when you feel rich you act rich and you
get better richer results so sometimes
it's alright with living in a little bit
of you know to have a bit of money I
start the way you just blow it out fun
with it because you don't want to be
thinking constantly from a position of
it a lot yeah or save safe right
contracts yeah what kind of agreements
do you need for a lease option agreement
and how did you get access to the
contracts honestly the best advice I can
give for this many people ask me on a
daily basis our phone calls about it
it's obviously on the YouTube video
comment section find a solicitor that
specifically specializes in dealing with
Lease Option agreements yeah just go for
a solicitor and then people car just
loads more money and what about this and
wanna but I don't think do you know at
the end of the day in order to get it
tight get it sealed get it done just go
find this list of the day it's you don't
need a solicitor but then what will
happen is at the end of the five years
yeah if the seller goes I don't want to
sell yeah you're very very vulnerable
position to lose waits for the solicitor
to drop contracts you need the right
solicitor it doesn't cost thousands it's
in the hundreds yeah and and it just
means that it's secure then doesn't it
so yeah absolutely
it's watertight and its peace of mind as
well how long did it take for the
property to go through once you'd seen
it what the whole process yeah about a
week
it really was is really really quick so
you had this referred about this guy
you're speaking over the phone you know
you talked to him about the idea of a
lease option agreement yes finally
situation first yeah talk about the idea
he's open yeah well yeah I exhaust all
the options and when you say talk to the
guy over the phone a lot of people cover
that bit up it's really important that
that meeting is this is what I can offer
these are the benefits these are values
this is what I bring to the table yeah
it's not just a standard conversation
it's like you know properly well thought
out there's the trick a lot of people
stumble at that point and that's why
I've got so many people phoning up going
I've tried to do and it's not worked
what would be your advice and I think
you've got to be totally on it you need
to understand what exactly what it is
that you can offer that person yeah how
you gonna relieve their stress help them
and and do that that's never
underestimate that bit that's really
really important than meeting or the
talking over the phone massively
important to answer your question after
that is pretty much plain sailing
because how can it not be you know they
you want to take that property off them
they want help you're giving them help
I'm happy he's happy so it's it's just a
case of like let's get it let's get this
done let's do this
love that real fast yeah so what do you
do I know you working the opposite of me
and they got do it's your job I'm a
sales executive I used to be a teacher
and I'm loving it it's amazing right and
you kick ass and thing is when you're
selling I know you sell out.i courses
our programs I do but it's not really
like sales it's more just like just
advising people you know how they King
Brooke on course is helping them do it
yeah I agree a lot of people let's be
honest right a lot of people that when
they when they hear the word sales they
think are sleazy sales slicked back hair
the furthest away you are 19:52 you know
you are a man of integrity
you left you job as a head teacher
because you were believe in the vision
what we do here in the office you do a
great job and if anyone who is watching
this who wants to do any of my training
or a course is the crash course or the
Academy or whatever I know you'll help
them absolutely and you know what give
me a call I'm so happy to help you give
me a call advice anything property
relate yeah I'll help you and if you've
not done it this isn't a plug this you
the crash course you can see from the
video for
has taught me how to do this yeah so if
you are interested in it and you know
about wasting time or asking silly
questions you just want to take action
just give me a call give you our
physical ask for Dave Mason or one of
the team's enough to be me so I will put
the number below which is oh three three
oh yeah oh one oh yeah oh seven for 200
a month readable o1 o2 714 Oh whatever
I'll put it in the link below guys I
hope you enjoyed that final words of
advice from Dave really simple this two
things actually take action yeah and the
next one is the Naik motto which I
believe is just do it guys I hope you
found that useful answering all Dave's
questions if you would like to come on
my youtube channel because you've had
some success in property or you know
someone that needs to come on then hunt
them down tell them they need to come on
and don't forget to message us and be in
touch enjoy peace out I'll see you next
time